if i wake up and everybody in my family
is alive i'm so [ __ ] fired up i don't
watch [ __ ] i don't listen to [ __ ] i'm so
grateful
gratitude it's just gratitude like one
life one at bat one time i'm fascinated
by people thinking that gratitude is the
same word as complacent i think people
mix words a lot
[Music]
the biggest fear i have is for the
people that are actually having success
because complacency kicks in and you
just get into pattern recognition
when it's about getting a watch
or
buying a new home
or getting a new pair of yeezys you're
finished and so i see a lot of people
looking for quick highs
i want to get that girl i want to get
that guy i want to get that plane i want
to get that you know car
that is just not sustainable everybody's
looking for so much outside validation
that they're impatient they want to show
everybody they're successful thus
they're rushing into things you have 23
year olds who think that they don't have
their life figured out yet they're
living for another 80 years
what progression
title
extra zero in your bank account
buying dumb [ __ ] happiness is the
[ __ ] progression most people hear the
word patience and have it confused with
complacency laziness lack of ambition
it's not true i actually think patience
has been foundational my success i
decided to build my dad's business for
him for the first 12 years of my career
that required huge patience from
somebody who thought they were great i
didn't even start quote unquote until i
was 34
patience is huge it's huge and people
don't want to do it because they want
instant gratification and more
importantly instant outside validation
i mean i am so competitive and hungry
it's probably inappropriate at the same
token
i genuinely am content
being content and grateful for what you
have and not envious for what you don't
have
while still being ambitious is a
different way to think about being
satisfied
you know there's a reason why there's a
word called gratitude and there's a
reason why there's a word called
completeness and i use gratitude and
patience a lot and i think people think
it's an excuse for laziness or not going
to get it and i laugh at that because
there's a whole other world that things
that i'm saying go too hard and all this
does on both sides of the
conversation is exposes people for
finding in my message what they're
looking for which is cynicism their
cynical point of view i'm talking about
being grateful and patient while having
tremendous work ethic and tenacity and
ambition gratitude is my fuel i'm
grateful
it's like i'm alive
yeah i keep things very basic as long as
my family's healthy
it's hard for me to get down
and so i'm just grateful you know
when you're like i cannot believe i'm
alive thank you so much
and oh my god i can't wait to wake up
and fight and grind and try to win i
love the game
you're unstoppable
[Music]
you